powerpoint materials um not like the big
slide see the whole powerpoints here i
know yeah yeah okay
perfect awesome um
so thanks everyone for coming to this
session um we are happy to have matthias
cristiano telling us about uh two tensor
optimization problems from quantum
information
all right um thank you very much
for for the invitation to speak um i
have to apologize
um
maybe on
only at least three accounts
so first of all i didn't make it to
berkeley um it's it's really a pity
but i guess another greek letter is
haunting
uh the planet at the moment
the second thing it's kind of like my
15th hour
awaken going so i'm not as sharp as i
would hope i'd be
um
and i guess um
you know the third thing really is um
i'm going to tell you about about two
pieces of my work and
and you will see at the end of my
presentations of these two problems how
they're connected with actual
optimization problems um but but i think
there is many many connections we've
seen already to
um
to frank's talk uh on monday and
um and also uh peter peter's talk on uh
on representations etc uh just just
before um and and then uh this the sort
of like second to second part is really
prelude to full views talk actually i
don't know has he already spoken or is
he
no not yet
no not yet okay okay yeah i'm really
sorry i can't participate in the program
it's kind of like a midnight party over
here when it's running so i'll i'll do
my best to just as much as i can here
okay so let's get going oh here's
another apologies i usually have more
pictures in my slides
but i i did sign uh this document
um about about the recording and and
after having signed it i thought i'll
take some of those pictures out
um i was not sure about the copy right
there
okay here we go
um okay i'll give you some introduction
and many of you have seen it already but
i'll do it anyway um then i will tell
you about quantum entanglement and then
some stuff this is stuff i started with
uh
with michelle actually um
uh back in zurich and and this this is a
um
i hope you enjoyed this little wooden
wooden thing that i made out of wood uh
well i made it that wood and the most
difficult aspect of it
was actually to hold the lamps
so it would cast the three shutters
um
all right and then i'll talk i'll
[Music]
and then i'll talk about about quantum
matter and this is the second
optimization um
optimization inspired optimization
problem that i'll come to
okay
okay quantum entanglement and then
quantum matter two problems from quantum
information to your very prominent
problems
and i think um i hope they're interested
to the community
okay so so my intro really connects now
um quantum information to algebraic
geometry and i want to spend some time
on that to get that connection straight
and then once we have that we can play
with it okay so let's just do that let's
get going so we all um if you're not
from a quantum world um you like to
think about bits and bytes i guess but
um here we have three bits
um i indicate them by levels it's like a
level system
and
they can be all down or all up or in any
of the other eight states in quantum
mechanics we allow um we think of these
eight states as eight vectors in a
complex vector space
and thus naturally uh quantum systems
can be in superposition
so they can be
in they can be other vectors
they can be linear combinations of these
vectors
okay so so this is just a way to think
about it
and to just take superpositions of zeros
and ones
it's somehow very strange and it's not
the same as as taking a certain thing
with a certain probability
yeah so here is it mathematically you
choose a basis for two-dimensional
vector space
and then you take the three-fold tensor
product and you manufacture a state in
it or you you bring your system and it's
indeed possible people have done that in
laboratory
to produce
descriptions of quantum systems that are
all down
and all up
with a 50 50
[Music]
50 50 years superposition
so um and and these things are really
done routinely now in laboratories
around the world and i think uh if you
see what is happening um to quantum
computing as a research field at the
moment the fact that we can do that the
fact that the
the quantum states i'm writing down now
are actually being able to produce in
that this is somehow what is what is the
difference between now and 20 years ago
and this is what's driving all this
excitement
um but
but in many problems in quantum
information theory
um the
these complex vector spaces
actually don't necessarily we don't need
to endow them with an inner product
so normally in quantum mechanics it's
it's the inner product is very important
and that has to do with connecting it to
probabilities and it's known as the
bourns rule
um and so in quantum mechanics if you
open any book in quantum mechanics it
will start by saying well let there be a
little bit space okay every physical
system has an associated space but
hilbert's base means it has an inner
product
and
and so if we
for some problems the inner product is
less important than for others so if we
look at problems where we can neglect
the inner product then it's just vector
spaces so we just have the sensor
product of the vector spaces and then
i'd like to to call it the tensor so i
just have an element and it's a tensor
product of three spaces and instead of
three you could look at two or you could
look at one or you could look at many um
three turns out to be a nice number
because two the case of two is fairly
simple to handle and um
in the case of three is sort of like the
simplest non-trivial case
so we'll already just write down t in a
basis so i choose a basis e i for my
first vector space and the basis of j
for the second basis k for the last
um and i i drop uh i drop the symbol for
it makes it different but i could choose
different bases for this
space if i wanted and then i have the
coefficients so t i j k and i call that
my tension
um
now
oh okay i noticed it's actually very
slow to transition it seems
i have a problem with the slides now
sorry for this there's some problem um
it was very slow so i
hope it didn't
okay so i'm i'm back here and i'm still
hoping to
poof
okay i don't know what the problem is um
okay i'm a little bit stuck i'm sorry
for this now i have to go out of the
slideshow i don't know why there's a
problem with the speed of the slides
it doesn't want to transition as i
wanted to can you try closing any other
programs you might have open
yeah can you assume
is it
is it actually slow on your end uh yes
yes it was actually slow on mine
closing microsoft word maybe that is
the culprit
okay i apologize for that i'm
um
closing one of the other
now most of it should be closed
okay
i'll continue
no i think yeah oh it comes okay great
let's see otherwise i don't know what to
do um
okay so there are some special states
and we have already seen zero zero zero
plus one one one state but i can do this
also for for r levels and i can take the
sum over the first r
okay
um now i in in quantum mechanics or in
any physical theory the important thing
is not only what the states of the
system are but rgb that i want to
compute on them
so what do i do what i compute normally
on is is kind of like for instance a bit
flip or conditional bit
and in quantum mechanics the same
happens here then right it's just a
it's represented with with a nice
operation on my space with the linear
operation on one of the factors if i do
say operations that are local okay so if
i just on the first on the first quantum
bit i do a bit flip and then it will
just swap e0 and e1 for instance
okay and this is the way i'm i'm making
transitions
um in my in my system
so that corresponds to applying the
matrix 0 1 1 0 to the first factor for
instance
okay this is not going well
um
maybe i can
what do our technicians say
um
here's what i'll do i will just move to
um
to or doing pdf is that okay
yeah pdf is uh okay i'm sorry for that
i'll stop sharing
um
i'm sharing pdf
now um
then it doesn't have the drop down of
course
but i hope it's still okay
it's better than having those hiccups
the whole time
all right
you can still enter a slide show okay
there that's fine i think we're going
like this i think it's the it's easiest
now to do that
okay
we're here okay
um okay so this all leads us to a notion
this operations on a quantum system that
leads us to notion that has been known
since the 80s
it's a notion on tensors called
restrictions
and it was sort of rediscovered in the
context of quantum information theory
and there it has this sort of
very
strange name local stochastic operations
um
and the um
and it's it's a pre-order on the tensors
it says that t is
bigger in this order than t prime
if i can
act
locally so on the individual spaces with
linear maps
a b and c
such that i obtain t prime from it and
this is
this is a standard uh notion now and in
the quantum context it corresponds to
um to doing quantum operations doing
measurements locally and to post-select
um so it's it's maybe a strange notion
but it does
um it does feature in in these two um in
these two optimization problems later um
especially in the second one it turns
out to be very useful
yes okay so um here is an example
uh an example of
um of understanding
in which way the um
just for for my case of c2 tends to c2
tensor c2
how
um what what this order does with with
all the possible tensors so it brings
them in some order um and
and you see
um that actually there are seven
um
six one two three four five and six and
there's also the null tensor
um these are
six
tensors
that
have the property that
they are their characteristic states for
for the orbits
under
um
under this restriction
okay so
if if you under restriction are so
restriction uh imposes
results in an equivalence relation
namely if you know one restricts to the
other and the other restricts one right
and then we say two are equivalent
and
so
any
uh tensor in in three qubits is
equivalent to one of these six states
um one of these six tensors and in in
addition
you have this hierarchy among them
okay so
the uh if you start here with the middle
one which is called the w state and
quantum information and then you can it
can restrict to uh to this state for
instance and you restrict by
um by applying a
map for instance you put on the last
part here you apply the map c that
that has e1 in the kernel
and then thereby you kill that term and
then you're left with these two terms
and then you apply this bit flip that we
had just before that swaps e0 or any one
on the first one and
suddenly you were given you are left
with e1 one
and plus e0 is zero and only the third
component you have to zero so this is a
way of going from the w state to
these um uh to to this state here which
is actually uh you see uh it's a little
unit matrix on the first two and then
quantum computing we call them einstein
rosenstein since they played an
important role in the paper from
by
these three authors
um so in this way
actually all of
um all of these three qubits can be
classified and of course this
classification from mathematical point
of view was already known in the 19th
century
so um
so this restriction if we now connect to
talks that we've already seen
then
then here is a definition again of
restriction and we we have this
equivalence notion so t is equivalent to
prime if it restricts both ways
and you see that if now the dimensions
are the same then actually that that
notion is equivalent to having um
to the orbits under the gl action
b of of the tensor t and the tensor t
prime being
um being equal
okay so you look at t and you look at
all of the things that are equivalent to
t or and you look at all things
equivalent to g prime
and
this way you can decide or in this way
you can see the classification
of restriction of this restriction
operation actually as a orbit
classification problem and it's a little
bit more than an orbit classification
it's really an orbit classification and
understanding the relations between
these orbits and how they relate and
that is why i showed you the graph for
me
now there was something that i i hadn't
told you before about and that is that
um
that this operation of restriction is
not closed in a sense so what can happen
is the following strange effect namely
that you know i'm going back to my
classification here that if you you see
here up here it says this zero zero zero
plus one one one state there is an error
to zero zero one plus zero one zero plus
one zero zero
but one thing that maybe many of you
know is that the the so-called tensor
rank of of this w state is actually
three and so the tensor rank cannot
increase on the restriction so how is it
possible that i put an error here from
something that obviously has tensor rank
two to tensor rank three
and and and the reason i put this error
is that that it's actually possible to
do this transformation approximately i
want to show you briefly how that goes
you um you manipulate so you send e0 to
e0 plus epsilon one and then you send e1
to minus c0 on all three factors and so
this one here is equivalent to this um
which i called the ghz state of the
green verb coinciding estate but now you
do an epsilon expansion and you see that
in zeroth order
zero times a three
the zeroth order is vanishing so in in
first order you've got something epsilon
and then suddenly you've got this thing
that has rank speed so it sort of like
emerged out of this limiting procedure
and therefore and here is actually a
kind of nice illustration if you think
of of of the left hand side here right
if you think of all of the things that
are product as
um as this curve right it's like a cubic
curve
if you think of this cubic curve here
and then
um this this difference of these of
these two points on this cubic curve so
the red point is e zero tensor three all
right and
this point here is e zero plus
epsilon um
e one
tends to three and then what you do is
so so then somewhere on this line okay
somewhere on the sequence we have just
the sum or the difference of two so
somewhere on the secant and what happens
now is that when we take the limit and
we take epsilon two zero right we move
here
and so on and then it it crashes it's
all geographic jumpers actually say
crashes in so phobia would say that it
crashes into the e0 over here
and then what happens is that the
resulting state it lies on the tangent
so it's not the secant
um and so therefore it doesn't have ring
two but it's its attention to this
um
to this
to this curve
and so this gives rise to a notion of
degeneration so t he generates ct prime
if i can find a sequence of tensors so
in
parameters per epsilon that actually
approaches t prime
such that you know t restricts to t
epsilon so it's really the the closure
operation i can from t go arbitrarily
close to uh 2t prime
and so what we see then is that deciding
degeneration is actually classifying
over closures and their
and and therefore and and you know orbit
closures are gelled right in uh gene
varian dodge bright varieties and of
course that's that's nice we can you
know use the machinery um from from
algebraic geometry now to attack this
problem and
and uh people have done so and
as i mentioned already for a very long
time all right so you could for instance
say t doesn't yeah t doesn't um
uh doesn't need gender t prime if and
only if there is a polynomial a g
covariant polynomial
such that it has two it has different
values on this
um and an example is of course now um
the backwards way okay so if we take the
key hyper determinant of course k that's
a long time ago and it evaluates to zero
on this w state but it doesn't evaluate
to zero on this g z state so we cannot
actually go up
um now if we and and this now i think
now leads us to a full understanding and
for a higher number of particles higher
dimension really we don't know how to
deal with this and i think this is sort
of um uh i want to highlight that
that it really is unintractable right so
you just go a little bit higher and it
feels intractable and
um
and um yeah
now in quantum information to you what
we like to build and i think it's really
like a general computer science theme of
course is we like to understand
resources and in this particular case
it's a resource theory of tensors where
you think of the tensor as a valuable
resource and you ask yourself
how does it how does this resource
transform under um under restriction so
restriction is the three operations i
um are under this resource theory and i
have a unit
it's kind of like a unit money somehow
um of of counting and then of course i
have a price i have a price for the
tensor how much of this unit r do i have
to pay to for my intensity
how much it cost
and this is typically known as the rank
um maybe somehow more more natural would
be to take the logarithm okay so you'll
see that later
all right so if you think of
the tensor as
expressed in
quantum bits and you look at a large
system
um and you think it's like the analog of
bits right in your communication
infrastructure you would usually pay per
per megabyte right you wouldn't pay per
per number of levels so per two to the
megabyte so so it's it's more usual more
and more natural actually to look at the
log rank and the the lob suffering so
suffering is what you get when you sell
it on
quantum ebay again you take your tensor
you you sell it and how much of this
unit tensor do you get back when you
when you sell it that's that's the sub
rank
or the log suffering it's the money you
get
any questions at this point
you are welcome to ask questions i hope
you can hear me
yes
okay great
um okay so that was the prelude um
quantum entanglement how to test for it
how to measure it okay
so you you
so we're basically uh in for
understanding how how much tensors cost
and how much we get for them when we
sell them
um
and we call that entanglement usually
okay so here is a way of
of understanding it and um in one way
goes by understanding these polynomials
better right so you see okay so these
are open closures of gene variant
algebraic varieties let me use
polynomials to um
to distinguish them
and these polynomials they come in
different types and uh and these types
are indicated by so-called highest
weights if you think of the gl
uh representations or you can think of
them as
young tableau if you or young young
frames if you
um if you if you run the whole thing
once through show while duality uh you
have this duality between gl and the
symmetric group so you can you can take
either viewpoint um so since we have a
triple of gl
whatever comes out will be a triple of
young diagrams
um to to understand this okay here's a
show about the construction okay it's
it's kind of very nice you take cd
tensor n and then cd tensor n you see
has a very natural action of the of gl
or also of the unitary group that peter
uh used
and uh in is a diagonal action so all of
the particles are rotated in the same
way and also it has a symmetric group
acting and the two are maximally
commuting so there's nothing more that
commutes than these two and so we get
this really nice uh one-to-one
identification
so what then happens is what you can do
is you can say well okay so let me
project let me look at the these parts
okay so let me kind of like look at the
irreducible parts of
my tensor in some sense so i take a high
tensor power and then i'm i'm projecting
this tensor i'm just looking at the sub
matrix gigantic submatrix if you want
and i'm asking myself um what this is
and what properties it has
and
and then we can do a first relaxation
namely we can
we have this if and only if up here all
right there is the g covariant
polynomial but if we don't look at the
polynomial itself we look only at the
diagrams because for a given diagram
there are many polynomials okay so
um many polynomials for given diagram so
we're not going to look at uh all the
polynomials we're just looking at the
diagrams and we just ask you know
is there a lump this and this is um you
know it's sort of a relaxation right
this you could have called an f you
could have called an obstruction but now
of course these here are occurrence
obstructions so does the lumbar occur in
geometric complexity
okay and um and we do another relaxation
and this brings me to a work that i've
done
time ago
um namely the concept of entanglement
polytope so it's another relaxation
because we're like saying okay you want
to look at this diagram well why don't
you why do you only look let's only look
at the
let's actually only look at the length
of the rows i'll get the ratios of the
length of the row so we normalize
everything by the total number of boxes
and then instead of the diagram four
three one
we get this um four eight three eight
and one eight and then of course you see
if i double the row length i'll get the
same point here so it's another
relaxation i'm just asking you know is
there for for for some number of box so
given such a this is the probability
distribution of course given for a
probability distribution is there some
number of boxes such that you know this
this is non-zero
and and then it comes the first surprise
so the first surprise is that um that if
you're given a tensor and say you're
given a tensor like the ghz tensor
um ah so so maybe one thing that to
remark right it's clearly gl invariant
this notion of whether or not there is
so for every um orbit
right and actually orbit closure because
it's for degeneration
um
for every orbit orbit closure there will
be a set right there will be a set of
of of of these probability distributions
and a big surprise is that this set of
probability distributions
is actually forming a convex polytope
and here you have the
four convex polytopes or maybe
what what is it six right six corner
polytopes because to each entanglement
class that i had shown you before their
corresponds this convex polytope and
here is the first one that's the biggest
one
it's also called the chronicle marginal
polytope
then the next one is this w polytope
which is kind of like a part of that you
see
and you remember the w lies in the
closure of the gh set so the the
corresponding polytope um should also be
in contained in this one and then these
uh the the einstein belongs to frozen
things here they each form a polytroph
so there are three lines these h
polytopes and then of course product
state
is also a quality
um
all right
so these are entangled polytopes and
they have surprisingly a dual
characterization
and this dual characterization is
illustrated with my little
wooden
wooden figure that i built
if you think of the tensor and now i use
t prime here as my tensor if you think
of the t prime as
the um
as as the wooden object
then
the three shadows
are
our shadows
are sort of like partial information
about it right
so and i can ask so given any wooden
structure i can ask myself which triple
of shadows do they
cast and given three shadows i can ask
is there a wooden object that casts
those three shadows
um i guess that's
you know
what you have also in medical
imaging that you want to you you get you
get a bunch of shadows you can go
backwards
and um
and this also we want to do in quantum
right so we are we're given or we we
have this tensor and we ask ourselves
which three shadows does it cast what do
i mean by a shadow a shadow is basically
for us it's kind of like a property so i
have this three particle quantum state
it's a property that is only dependent
on one of the particles
and so in this particular case it just
means that okay what i can do is i can
only look at that part i'm doing that by
grouping all the others together so i
have two parts one versus the rest
and actually kind of like the one versus
the rest um
this will actually tell me
it's all the information i can i can
extract from this one particle and what
is this information um the gl and
variant part of that information is is
the singular values of the map that goes
from here to here and then i square the
singular values and then actually if i
normalize my state here to be normalized
so it has a norm one then um now i
sneaked in in a product of course
um then
then actually these singular values the
formal probability distribution
so my shadows for my tensor here are
three probability distributions so one
for a
one for the c
and one for the b particle put your head
sideways
all right
okay so now um
and now you're like okay great so i can
take this this t and mathematically i
can put in
map framework that's exactly what frank
talked about um but i wanted to give you
this sort of like parts of the physical
intuition of of why we were uh doing
that because
also this way of thinking that i was
trying to present to you now is also
something that that generalizes beyond
settings which can be dealt with
with help of moment maps
so here's a big surprise okay so one big
surprise that's the theorem by prion
that we applied to
to uh to our particular case then
to this triple gl action case is
that the two polytopes uh that that the
first polytope that i showed you before
it's actually the same as if you look at
the collection of shadows okay so if i
give you a triple of shadows
for the qubits
then the corresponds to just one point
in the poly hole
and i give you the triple of shadows so
i so every triple of shadows corresponds
to one point i ask which triple of
shadows are possible
and they actually don't just form an
arbitrary arrangement of points in in r3
but
they they form this convex polytroph
namely for this this one this one and
these three and
so this is actually a dual
characterization um for um
for
for the code
and actually we used it we um
you can use this this characterization
and you use it into in order to detect
whether something is entangled
um so we made a little um
entanglement test so if you want to for
instance figure out if if you are
greenberger or inside lingerie entangled
or if you're a w entangled and w is
weaker so you want again you want to
show to the world that you built this
new machine that has a quantum state
that's
better entangled than the previous
machine that was being built so all you
have to do according to our test
is you have to show that that when you
measure locally the particles
you are the the image of that point is
not in the blue part and
then you like now you build a really
good quantum device and this is a way
to to to certifying entanglement and and
the quality of your machine in some
sense
okay
and people have actually implemented it
in the lab
and um this is this is really quite nice
so
um
[Music]
uh yeah so i haven't really
told you now why or why the mathematics
is and i think there were other
you know we can talk about lately that
later
i want to bring you more of the quantum
information intuition
because in quantum information
um one thing
you know when i say quantum information
theory one thing is is that it includes
the words information
and that is of course going back to to
kill shannon in the 1940s and it's
really the backbone of everything we're
doing in the internet these days so how
how what is the basic model of
information theory it's that i have a
source that spits out
some data
that
then you have an encoder
that encodes the data such that you can
maybe transmit it or you can store it
maybe put it in storage and then you
decode it
and and what shannon realized was that
you could do much better than that
if
you
if you don't look at a source alone but
you look at many executions of resources
but like when i'm speaking i'm having a
strain of symbols is coming out and i'm
doing an encoder on a block on a big
block line
i'm doing an encoder
that's that takes a whole block and then
i'm storing that and i'm willing to
tolerate a small error and then i can
decode actually
but i used the storage cost
is much reduced the storage cost only
corresponds
to the shannon entropy of the random
variable that that represented the the
frequency with which certain symbols
emerge from the source
so one can dramatically reduce this the
storage cost and i think this is one of
the backbone really of a lot of
information
um
now
in the quantum world
yeah in the quantum world
this this
this point of making sources
it's it's really it's really the same
instead of a
symbol written on a piece of paper
it's spitting out a quantum particle in
a quantum state
and the model of having an iid
distribution like here an independent
identically distributed source
is really in the quantum information
beyond
the tensor product that connects
quantum states with the tensor product
so
um oh i wrote it down for general field
f okay so f is now the complex numbers
again
um so so if you think of now right so
independently sampling first t versus
tensor right or tensor is now a triple
of particles and then independently
having a triple of sources that spits
out another intensity prime
we have to you know that's a very
natural operation it's really the one
that you know every experimentalist
every day in the lab does every quantum
experimentalist whenever they press the
button and if they press the button of
the machine independently um independent
copies come out
so let me illustrate how this tensor
product now now works in in some ways
and i'm sure uh you know
um
many of you know this but i actually
thought it was kind of fun this skew is
the symbol for for our mathematics
center here in copenhagen so if you uh
and and i'm illustrating this now with a
uh with with a tensor which is matrices
just a tensor of two spaces and so i
have this little matrix which is blue
black
um yellow and green and i tensor it with
this cube well what happens oh the
colors don't seem to be perfect maybe
that was a transformation okay well
you see what it should be it just
duplicates the queue and it gives it the
corresponding color from over here
and now when we have tensors like we had
before that are three-dimensional arrays
of numbers
um then if if i take for instance a pair
of glasses and i i tensor it with this
unit tensor here which is uh just um
has something on the diagonal then you
see that i just get the glasses on the
diagonal with a certain color and it's
sort of also interesting to do it the
opposite way around right so if you
think of
this and then
you tensor it the other way around it
actually looks kind of different but
this is of course the same as that just
up to
writing in a different way
okay
are any questions to tense products and
how i illustrate it
i hope there's no copyright on these
classes i didn't check it
okay
um now what is interesting is this iid
idea right so i do independently and
identically distributed random variables
i wouldn't really think of it as
fractals right but if i'm
if i'm doing this with my tensors
then you know one goes to t
t tends to two t times a three etc
and i think of the t tensor two right
it's three particles and three particles
but i don't think of it as
as as three particles and three
particles but i kind of like when i do
the tensor product i think of the
resulting thing again as three particles
okay so this is just on a bigger space
now
so what happens is that here i had gld
gld gld acting and i have here gld gld
gld when i combine them i have the
action
is gld squared gld squared gld squared
all right if i take the n full tensor
product f gl d to the n acting on the
individual ones
so if you do this with matrices what you
actually get is an example is here the
sipinski carpet
um
which kind of looks nice
and
i couldn't find the public domain manga
sponge but if you type it into google
there's there's tons of
uh illustrations of it
okay so really it kind of like goes
fractal in some sense and and i think
this is also a bit mind-boggling that
nature is doing that to us
leading us though to now an asymptotic
resource deal okay so all this prelude
was now to motivate and to tell you that
the n fold iterated tensor product is
just as natural in quantum information
theory and it was for shannon to
consider iid random variables okay it's
really just as natural for us
and so it's supernatural to ask
when can i transform n copies of t
into n copies of t prime
and
and i can give little fudge factor a
little of n here to make to make the
whole theory a little more elegant
the unit's still the same
but you see that now
since i'm asking how can i
asymptotically transform resources
have now a notion of of asymptotic rank
namely it's it's kind of like the
asymptotic cost
okay if i want to buy many copies of t
how much do i have to pay in terms of
gsat state of course naturally right i
would like to take the log of this again
okay because it's really what i would
have to pay
money and this is what i would get on
ebay again right the log sub rank of
this
okay it's a very natural resource theory
and in quantum information we have
looked at many resource theories before
somehow um one considered what we have
considered this asymptotic resource
theory but i think it's more than the
more natural ones
and then
[Music]
of course uh considered it and maybe
that is what connects me also to peter's
talk and to frank's talk i should say
that that uh if faker strassen um
considered this for the case
uh in the 80s he considered this for the
case where was where um what he you know
he looked at the case where t prime
is the um
uh is the matrix multiplication tensor
of 2x2 matrix multiplication
and um uh and then here t is the
um sdu
is the um
is the
the ghz state that i showed you before
this unit this unit tensor
so the asymptotic rank of the matrix
multiplication tensor here is really um
is two to the omega right so omega again
is like log of that and so it's very
natural to take the log of this and then
the matrix multiplication coefficient
can be cast is actually equal to the
asymptotic current of
um
of the matrix multiplication test
all right so then strassen hammered away
at this okay so he just uh
he he defined the problem and he just
hammered away that he came up with this
nice theorem the theorem says that um
that if
i'm gonna do it for time okay well i
should speed up a little i guess
um
he says he he showed that that functions
f
that track
okay so functions f that are monotone
under restriction
okay so
you know look at functions that are
monotone under restriction because
monotones are usually good ways of
finding lower bounds on things right so
if
if if under some al if if you you know
well you know that right so monotones
are are the way to get obstructions
and um and he actually showed and this
is sort of like this is the this is the
non-trivial part that there's a complete
set of monotones of a certain structure
and the structure is that these
monotones are actually multiplicative
and additive
okay so there he defines a ring of
tensors and these are actually ring
homomorphisms
and these are homomorphisms that have
this monotonicity property
so it's it's really kind of a beautiful
theory of obstructions
with a lot of structure
and these obstructions allow you then to
to to to say something right to to
understand the asymptotic range and play
something
so here are some examples okay so what's
uh what's in what's what's such a
monotone
ring homomorphism right and you all know
them
and love them it's matrix right
okay so the um if you look at matrices
um and and the matrix rank is such a
nice function it's if you take direct
sums of matrices it adds up if you take
uh
tensor products of things it just
multiplies just as i showed you it's
normalized if you put the unit tensor
and it's d it's monotone right the
matrix length of this is two the matrix
strength is swan etc
okay these are really nice examples so
all you have to do is you have to take
the tensor you have to um um well okay
so all you have to take your tensor you
have to flatten it like i did before all
right so i group two of them like i make
this kind of shadow thing and then you
apply and then you compute the rank okay
great that's that's one of the these are
three points right these are three
uh three nice monotone functions and
they call the gage points they're very
nice
but but the strassen showed for for
other rings and mitch's multiplication
he sure gave a bunch of beautiful
constructions for
um for such functions but he didn't have
them in general so um
so in joint work with peter fauna and
the wounds out them we actually were
able to interpolate if you want between
these extreme cases
and i want to show you because it's an
optimization problem okay so it's an
optimization problem over
uh entanglement polytopes
this is also what frank talked about so
it's really an optimization problem what
we're doing is
and i want to advocate a little bit for
that so so let's let's say we want to
interpolate right so we'll interpolate
we want to kind of like take the average
of these
of these ranks right these nice
ranks that i've showed you
and how do i do that
well
i
what i do is actually i'm
um
i'm choosing a weighting on how i want
to average so let's just say a third or
third a third not to get confused
and then
i'm taking um i'm looking at the point
in the entanglement polytope remember
these points and tangent polygons are
triples of probability distributions
so i'm taking this a triple of
probability distributions and what do i
do with the triple a probability
distribution well i think back to 1940
and i take the average shannon entropy
okay so let's just do that
and it's just the average shannon
entropy what to do else with with with
probability distributions
and uh and then you compute this e okay
and now because this rank is defined so
we have to take the exponent of it
so but what is important is that if you
think back of your entanglement polytope
it's really computing a distance to the
origin okay what's the origin in this
thing is always um
the origin is the points
okay so what's the the the origin okay
so let me connect to
um frank's talk
is
the origin is so
i guess the tensor okay the tensor
corresponding
so the if if a tensor has a
corresponding polytope that does not
include the origin
then
um then the tensor is in the null column
okay so that's that's the connection
it's a connection there
but given that it is not in the nullcone
or
in general what we can do is we can try
to compute
the distance to the origin okay so if we
try to compute the distance from here
right we'll somehow you know we start
here we're trying to compute we're
trying to get closer to the origin we
get stuck somewhere over here
and and we we can kind of like wonder
how big this distance is
now
um now what instead of computing a
distance here what i'm actually doing is
i'm maximizing the entropy here so i'm
i'm kind of like maximizing and the
entropy would be maximal if i end up
down here but maybe i get stuck
somewhere before
and how i'm i'm doing that i have
different ways of doing that i have
different ways of doing this maximum
entropy principle if you want i can wait
the the three coordinates in different
ways namely with my theta parameter and
this way i get a bunch of different
distances
and i think these are really interesting
distances and and
and i i think in maybe the the
literature and moment polytopes and so
on what people have considered a lot
worse was was um for being used norm
distances so like uh um
squared basically matrix squared
distances but this here is really
different right it's a shannon entropy
distance
and the question is of course how do we
optimize over this and and i think this
is what i hope you you will become
interested in as a problem
okay well
um long story short the important
property proof is multiplicativity and i
showed you two ways of looking at the
tensor at the
polytope and you know multiplicativity
you have to prove sub-multiplicative
super multiplicativity so it's these two
characterizations that they are equal
and actually give you the multiplication
all right that was part one i guess i
told you
um
everything
about these functionals now and i have a
few minutes maybe left to go to part two
or is there times if you want to have
questions now
i can just say a few words about the
um
remaining part
maybe go go ahead and continue
okay um okay so the the the second part
is really a
tenses now in a different way okay so
i'm i'm now going back i think that what
what i was really interested in was
that
that i can treat the tensors for the
geometry
now what i want to impress that tool
and i want to use it in the context of
tensor networks intense networks of
course different relevant in different
areas of science they're
machine learning and but they're also
interested in physics and in
in in order to describe quantum matter
and
and in in physics typically if you have
some crystal or some some crystal
structure you would you you you build
these tensor networks out of regular
graphs right so you you take a graph
and then what people do is
um uh they actually pla um they actually
place small tensors here on the vertices
of of this graph so if i think of a
graph right so look at this if you see
that look at this picture you see that i
actually made the graph in such a way
that
um that i want to think of the graph as
consisting of a bunch of edges really
and then of having the vertices at the
end of the edges
being kind of like
you know grouped together okay so this
is how i want to think about it
and then i want to um i want to and then
here i i would want to look at at linear
maps applied to these to these vertices
so if you if you lay out um such a graph
and then you you you um you attach a
a tensor to each of
each of the uh each of the edges
all right and what a tensor do we
associate because it's just
an edge i can associate a matrix to it
and then i can apply
i can apply
linear maps to the vertices and this
actually is a tensor network this is
what people call a tensor network
and so one thing that we tried and what
you found was a lot of fun
was was looking at tensor networks where
where i'm not applying where the
underlying graph
is not it's not a graph but it's a hyper
graph okay so i'm starting out from a
hyper graph and on the hyper graph i can
associate different types of entangled
states or different types of tensors to
the hyperedges and then apply these
linear maps because what happens then
certainly is that i get really
interesting stuff also on the boundary
because because because of the
because these application of the maps
which is really the operation of
restrictions is not closed
and so we we what we what we did
was we we took
we took a very particular uh type of of
tensor network
and we were able to
to improve on its on its efficiency and
in its representation with help of
geometric methods imported from
algebraic complexity theory and i think
this is really nice payoff of the
connection okay so we could make
progress in this problem uh uh coming
from quantum information theory and
actually it's sort of like an important
uh state an important tense network
description for the resonating valence
bond state the resonance bond state is
sort of a it's a state that people think
is sort of like the model of
superconductivity
so this for this model of
superconductivity we're able to give a
more succinct tensor network description
uh with help of insights from
ultraviolet complex
and um and we did that by by by swapping
out the entanglement structure with with
help of tools but i'm it's going a
little bit too
um
and let me let me tell you that aspect
so
basically um you basically the numerical
code or
things that people use in order to
analyze tensor tensor networks is
usually based on these on these normal
on these normal graphs
and we were playing
we were playing and finding more
efficient structures
for um
more efficient representations of this
of the superconducting state
and so all we had to do in the end was
was transforming certain small tensors
on the
on the plaquettes and so
really we reduced the problem
to a problem of reducing of
understanding the connection between two
tensors with help of restriction and
degeneration just that i had introduced
earlier so even though we're looking at
a state on this vast network
right arbitrary sized net tensor network
we could reduce important properties or
did use important properties by looking
at
at
local plaquettes so it's single tensor
transformations and as as people know
they play with single tension
transformations they're already very
difficult okay at this and we had to
employ a lot of algebraic geometry in
order to understand
so really we were able to uh to
understand these uh these restrictions
of the states that are relevant and and
come out relevant in
in this in this area of physics
and we're able to um
to make sense out of this approximate
out of going to the closure okay so
previously people had observed that when
you do numerical procedures and you try
to understand tensor networks and to
minimize um and to find the optimal
tensor network representing your
physical state but people had realized
that at certain points
you you actually kind of like you take
off and you go to a boundary so the
problem becomes ill-conditioned
and so we were able to connect that
phenomenon in this in this case to the
phenomenon of a closure phenomenon
algebra geometry and i think phobia will
will tell you more details about it
um but that is sort of what what i
wanted to give you you know home on on a
high level that
what we were able to do was what was
connecting these tools to multivariate
geometry so we use interpolation theory
um and all sorts of tools that have been
developed in algebraic geometry and in
algebraic complexity theory very
successfully
um
and in the end i think we um
so we we had our little application um
that is a new and more efficient
representation for this resonating spawn
state
um
and
and with this i think i'm i'm done and i
want to tell you on the very last slide
what this has to do with optimization
and that is because in physics when you
look for
when you're interested in certain
physical state describing a system
what you're really doing
is that you start off with an
understanding of how the energy in the
system comes about for instance
how the interaction of particles so here
for instance i have an energy diagram so
if you think of two hydrogen atoms and
these two hydrogen atoms you bring them
either far apart
or you bring them closer together or you
bring them super close together right
you can't put them on top of each other
so the energy would be too high
and if they're far apart
um then they act like an independent
system so they have a bound state at a
certain distance when the energy is is
small so how does one compute that well
you make a variational so you have an
expression for your hamiltonian which is
which is basically a gigantic matrix
stress
and you you minimize right you do a
variational principle and you minimize
uh over all the possible steps and
people do that in condensed matter of
course with unreally large systems they
minimize and and they have found out
that it's really good idea to minimize
over these tense network states
so minimizing tens network states
is really a very important second
optimization problem in quantum
information and the work i've just
presented to you has to do with the
question of how stable are these
minimization procedures or other things
on the boundary and and i i hope that at
least inspires
some thought for people thinking about
this
thank you
thanks um
any questions
i i have a question uh
what are the physics problems you're
trying to solve with these with these
tensor networks
um
what is the physics problem
yeah
like
yeah what what is the sort of physics
that you're trying to model
with these
with this like lattice tensors on a
lettuce sort of thing right so so what
people um
uh
trying to do
is basically
um
basically tensors on the lattice have
the property
so so the the tensors
or the tensor networks
they are a very small part
of all the possible tensors that are
there right of all the possible quantum
states i could represent
so because the the number of quantum
states or the dimension of your quantum
space explodes exponentially with the
number of particles
one has to somehow in a any variational
procedure narrow the search space so one
starts with the and one has found out
that a good idea is to
is to um
is to look at at at states that are only
that only have local correlation
so the the correlation is of a fixed
size between nearest neighbors
and
and with this
tense networks represent a class of
states that actually
model very successfully the correlations
that states in nature have or that we
observe okay so if you um
this has to do with what we call the
area law that the the amount of
entanglement in physical states kind of
like grows
in proportion to the perimeter of
um of an area and and thereby in these
states are a good class okay so
sorry i guess the question is like what
is the energy that you're interested in
like what is the
what are you minimizing
once you have the sensor network what
are you what you're minimizing is is
typically um um it's
it's an energy that is a sum
over energies of say nearest neighbors
in the letters okay so for every nearest
neighbor
um you have an energy so think of think
of electrons or think of other particles
right they they will interact mostly
with their neighbors right
and so you you have some energy
corresponding to two neighbors
interacting and you just sum up all of
these contributions
and that gives you that gives you the
hamiltonian the energy function so it's
a it's a huge
matrix
in in an exponentially sized space
and now you want to find the ground set
energy all right because you want to
understand you want to be able to draw
an energy diagram like i did here for
hydrogen
you want to draw some energy diagram
that will allow you to to say
um when you for instance have a phase
transition so when your system goes from
a phase that's akin to like gas into a
phase that's akin to a fluid or
a phase that's akin
to to assault it
and therefore you are trying to figure
out what is the ground state energy
does that does that make sense
uh yeah i think so i guess that you have
like some sort of frustration or
something where you
you have a lot of states that all have
about the same energy that's the
computational problem
like you have a lot of dipoles on the
vertices of it's a kagomi lettuce is
what people sometimes call this right
yes so so this was it was just an
example right yes yeah but in in in
general you have been in in many
circumstances you have complicated
minimization problems yes
frustration and and even without
frustration right you run into
uh you might find into problems
okay thank you
um other questions
um i i have one question which is like
when you're optimizing these matrix
product states
um
is there any structure you can exploit
or is it just kind of like still a
pretty
hopeless optimization problem in terms
of like convexity and stuff like that
um
what people tend to do is they well
there's maybe two um
uh
there's there's there's
two interesting aspects that i think one
is that one typically does an
alternating optimizations you optimize
one and you optimize the next and so on
and you go around in a circle if it's on
a circle or you go around in different
ways
um this is one way of
doing the optimization i think michelle
can probably say more about that
um in a second um and another another
very interesting thing i i think is is
on this on this graph
that if you
if you think of it as lying on a on a
taurus
so you you take the scratch you wrap it
around this way and and the other way
um then there are other ways of um
of of somehow going to the infinite
limit this is called infinite paths or
ipads so where you contract uh one ring
and then you uh
you you contract in sequence on the
other direction um but this assumes some
assumptions on like
invariants uh um that you have the same
that you you don't optimize different
ones but you use the same
um the same map and all of the sites
right so it will put some restrictions
on but it's a different different aspect
of the problem but maybe michelle can
say more about this optimization problem
yeah i mean i think in terms of rigorous
algorithms uh
i think in one dimension
somehow i mean there's this method that
you described and then i guess there's
some i don't see exactly who's in the
audience but i guess imagine and friends
have worked on uh
algorithms that i think are approaching
practicality um
in one dimension with guarantees
um and i mean they would construct by
some kind of recursive scheme uh good
matrix products data scripts i think in
higher dimensions i don't know if
there's
anything rigorous and efficient
yeah
well thank you um any other questions or
from the online audience
maybe i have a question
if i may um
about this uh conversion um
when you have this nice information
theory motivation and i guess there's
lots of variations you have the little
big o and a little off and uh that's
what we were not worrying about but i
guess another interesting relaxation is
if you don't demand exact conversion
between resources
let's save an error that's small and
going to zero as n becomes large
um
maybe i blanked and you commented it but
in case you didn't count in it maybe you
could say a few words so like is there
also such an approach can also define
functionals and study uh like you know
well okay so there's uh so peter has
thought about this problem and he has
done some very nice work on it um
but it's not the approximation in the
usual information theoretic sense that
we know from shannon right it's more um
it's more quantifying
it's more a deeper understanding of the
quantification of the
of the error
and and and that of course
um plays in and relates to to your work
with with frank right
um
because it has to do um
uh
right you had the you had these
hedgehogs with the um with these
functions and this rate function
um plays a role in these functionals
right these these these generalizations
of these functions they're defined
um
from
the rate function right which maybe we
don't know but they they take the
properties of these rate functions and i
think it's it's super interesting work
yes
um peter fauna is amazing and and this
work on the on the extension of these
pawn functions is amazing i
i think the the question of um
probability um
uh it's also amazing that it can be cast
in this framework
um
in general like approximating that would
require us to reintroduce inner product
in a more
deeper fashion and i failed to see how
to do that
so is the thing that peter looks at just
a peter farner looks at just to remind
myself is that like um if you look at
the probability of these src protocols
actually succeeding
it's your description but you you worry
about the okay
yes yes goes in that direction yes
um yeah so it puts that
in
thank you
all right
if there's no other questions let's
thank matthias again
[Applause]
thanks a lot for having me
and uh we come back at two
gonna go home